it's probably algorithms I can't
remember who it's by the textbook of
algorithms is fabulous lots of formal
Theory
um
yeah that's a terrible sign check
question
so before we start
um have you got a favorite computer
science book or a book that you uh you
know just so I can get your levels right
okay
um of course the best bit would be about
human computer interaction and research
methods for understanding how software
helps people rather than like how to
build software fair enough build it
right build it right okay what's your
favorite computer science book so it
doesn't have to be specifically computer
science but maybe that relates in some
way Ah that's a good question
um
well one of the first computer science
books I liked I don't want to rank them
in order but the first one I liked was
on Advanced algorithms something that I
don't
do anymore but
it was the first thing that really
excited me it got me into computer
science when I found a book that does an
undergraduate course at the right sort
of level and Andrew Tannenbaum you know
from
Friar University in Holland writes very
good books and certainly the stuff of
Brian's Brian's history and Memoir of
eunuchs have greatly enjoyed but in some
ways this is more General and I I would
certainly put it on my
top shelf no top shelf accessible shelf
for sure shortlisted shortlisted yes
sound check question then favorite can
be a size book at the moment my favorite
book is understanding cryptography by
Christophe Parr and Jan pelzel wonderful
book about cryptography I've been using
it to teach but it's that for me it's
that nice combination of practical
interesting how this actually works and
a bit of maths in there not too much
math because then I get scared off
viewers if this one looks crap it's
because Sean has got a new camera and he
doesn't know how to use it it's true
it's fine anymore there's some great
stuff going on the screen but I don't
know what any of it means or is it it
may even have image stabilization uh
yeah it's really good there's there's
very few computer books list all my God
what's your favorite book though Pride
and Prejudice okay there was no
hesitation though whatsoever fantastic
all right I know there's changes over
the years so yeah well for me I would
say say to a few people that I think it
depends on which week you're asking me
the best question because it would be
different I recently got right into
books through audible so I wrote about
300 in the past four years oh there are
some bangers in there which do I like
um
a bit of medical drama things like bad
blood about fairness and Elizabeth
Holmes that was a very good book there's
a book about sack the family but anyway
also um for some reason you can't help
you like 1960s
um sort of Soviet era spying things like
uh Kim philby
um Ben McIntyre writes a lot of books
don't know why I liked it so much but
yeah it's um it must be pretty tense
getting a sticky situation is fine
wasn't it yeah like every day and now
who do you believe who do you trust all
that stuff is crazy just so I can check
the mics working what's your favorite
book my favorite book is uh I think it's
called an English the glass marble game
by uh Hermann Hazard a Herman has okay I
should check that out yes it's a really
good fun book about uh sort of the
relationship between Academia and the
real world
um for all it's been written in the 19
30s I think
it's still quite relevant you have one
I'll tell you the book I've read
recently that I liked the most and that
was a book called Spy game by William
Buckley and it's based on the life of a
very famous
counterintelligence officer in the CIA
known as James Jesus Angleton and it was
it's a quite well written book although
Angleton basically only appears in half
the book but I would recommend that to
anyone if there are if they're looking
for favorite book for a books to read it
doesn't have to be computer science
could be anything could be a novel can
be a could be the dictionary I don't
mind whatever it is what's your favorite
book
uh that's a tough question but
it may have to be House of sleep by
Jonathan Koh okay we'll see about is it
a novel is it yeah it's a novel about
yeah it's a novel a work of fiction
about uh The Institute of the stories
about a group of people that uh so if
there's like a study about a group of
people that cannot sleep
and they put them together but it's a
lot of there's a lot of uh human
introspection and
I don't want to spoil too much but
that's I I think it's a also a lovely
way of writing and I was so engaged with
it and yeah
I very rarely read for pleasure because
I tend to read quite a lot for my job
and so I find I do other things like
coding and stuff for better or worse uh
I can read
um I do like a John Grisham uh yeah yeah
nothing wrong with that bit of lawyers
and you know murders and stuff
just to check the microphones working
then um what's your favorite book
um so my favorite book is the first 15
lives of Harry August by Claire North
uh contemporary British writer should I
tell you what what it's about yeah
so I don't want to spoil it too much for
people who still want to read it I it's
highly recommended so I'm not spoiling
it by telling you that the protagonist
is one of the people who can relive
their life over and over again while
remembering the previous lives
and if it sounds very philosophical it's
not it's actually this
um premise leads to very interesting
science fictiony and uh
um a kind of psychological right
implications like every life would be
slightly different
um and what happens to the knowledge
that he acquired before and how does he
use this knowledge
um anyway highly recommend it what's
your just checking the microphones
working what's your favorite book uh
favorite book I well the one I've read
the most often let's get let's get let's
give the intellectual answer pretend to
actually know what I'm talking about
which is I really like the acidity's
history of the uh Athenian Spartan War
mostly because it's has things like a
description of a tsunami in there uh 500
BC something that I didn't understand
existed until 2010. all right so uh just
to check the mic's working uh what is
your favorite book I I'd say
um
good Lasher Embark by Douglas hofstetter
which is yeah I think you're smiling
like you've heard this answer probably
several times
okay it's an absolute classic it's it's
old now I think it was the 70s or 80s
you call me a little by surprise with
the question but um
it's really imaginative playful look at
what is AI in the sense of general
intelligence before AI just became a
whole bunch of neural networks talking
to each other what might it mean to
think it's absolutely wonderful and it's
actually it's really comic
um so it's it's funny intelligent very
worth reading if computer science is
your thing my name is Perla mayodino my
favorite book is Alice in Wonderland ah
very good very good okay so tell me your
name and tell me what your favorite book
is in computer science then my name is
Marco camuri and my favorite book in
computer science is a modern effective C
plus plus my favorite book that's uh
that's not an easy one I've got a few a
few books that I particularly enjoyed
reading but one book that I've really
enjoyed lately was uh it's not actually
a book it's a is a series of Five Books
if I remember correctly by Martha Wells
the first one is called all systems red
and it's about a robot in the future
a security board to be more precise that
uh somehow manages to
override its uh Governor which is like a
a sort of module that guided Behavior
and what is your favorite book my
favorite book is a book called Hyperion
by Dan Simmons
the strike scary monsters yeah